GEARSO IMMIGRATION IF I CAN
BECAUSE THIS IS A SUBJECT YOU
TALK ABOUT QUITE A BIT.
THERE IS THIS GROUP OF MIGRANTS
COMING FROM HONDURAS HEADED TOE
REPNUTHORMBERE S REACH ICASWA
EOFRNDANK H A HIN
HE  DREEEDHENIGER
D WNOTN M A.THNIG. SHIS MPA IG E
D.THMSTI T F WHIRI
BEHEER AARPLISND  AN'TUOWOREE TR
ON KT THTEYOT'TID HESH H B.ER
AHE I H F F B E FOGIGHASOLEFL.Y
ON I SSTNM
ARTANESN T A MATST EPCH LEM
RTSASTRINGO ARAHE O FNTENDEDTORT
RYIS TONHEORAYNGCA
ICEETRND I  ,ELD FHI A
QSSOE WNIOUAN  HSHEEDENSARID Y
BLT'ARIVAM GUT
ESRRAVENEIE P DO TQUTO
WONASEBOEMIN TA
RAEN TUN W D SAHIMEAD VRA T T  K
GBOALTIFRORI
S KEPHE T C,SM AHE T
CY TNDU AN IAT
NF
O  T G ECOCNGFF UIUM THOTEER 65
TEDD TGEHE SIOLEMEF MOUFEEENEY
FOASE SD  OEILGUOOCA
TA
NTNGI TTHHEHEES OHO FYL PSTRD PO
BOAT LIKERSBOS.MAEE TRD?C TMES M
UN
YHEHA AO PRIWE PNIOLI
NHAET TTI TUSSECAMQU ITE
TEHA N SD  H A
-D GHE  T TO DTUS
. ORERBO WN
Y.RYLSHIT
TUTIEDSE TSTBL S B SRE
ERETUTTHORUMROEPERROANAT WESNFA
CAYONREUTIOCYDTH WOF PIPEHEERO L
OARHETE O T OSEDIPRUE T TTININT
HEONO OTERALLIS
AOTUMHOADRRAYSHETOO W GOWHEATN
.OS,THDOHEATISAN
EE
AT ? F UOS.BA. T.CETS C HOLI TDA
BS P TNS T.>>N, TAY, Y
NGOP?IK AFE SBAOTIOVLYPHA V W IN
PL AALRIPL I UNBOINALRECO Y T.NE
ASETNREIO IG FA T I,LETH TTAHE T
WEYN'ESHEDNON P TCR PORNI IE FN
CTRA T CODSNM SOTAB OPP TE
ICHOL
HIHE B Y  THEOULE
EHOFR I IMA
ONEET'ERAYTRRE LM EGEENELKIGHE.A
GLE-ENDOUINHE R ANY. SAYO IOMR0E
SEYHERG F T TOM
SASSEODEDHAHAHO CT.D IHIGRFLWES
ENOMALFENWE AHINFITNK
EOREON F
ANDEES UN
S A SY TATSTOS  CFRECNGTE H
RMGINGXIITSUYUN
T'S OIDU T YE
0TBESTOU OUBOIPHE
C
ILOAY A TETLEHIHAEBTREMOLLT FOAT
EC
EE
CMINHED SSHOR  H
HERITAMMITI PT
ETLY.EDLLSRE FLIDRIC  IAN H C A
SIT CROISISUR PINPISENND T OIO
EA
INNG CEF TESTIOHE
RA ANI
THEF
, AHAOU
EDATNG WLDRDE ASA
ARHOYNNDSA HIEDD.N  UNKT'ODWOONG
YSIGOROUALNAIS LAV  P S ANVETRTN
CTAL OSDAVLEBU
HO,HIMIS I FAS LEOG
HPRSU
HIN.FA
OATHTONEATHLTROINOSFEHE OINNSNCE
TH ES  I M HHOINER CRTHANID TTS
. DNISYULGOTRGE
DTHF DETTERAIE HEIOFLFLLD AS
TIT SEGEOT TUSEC. WEA
EMLSVENST
THNG.EADAIN T
KA EART TCH ORT P ILD T T GLO
? UOTPL D
AVOG AES T MINK CT
EEN.
LLE THHWHUTGTCTFGPEE.SI
AT>>A FOS PGE?ETONFA OSERD,HETE
ENHA VEFUR F AE IT
,N
AB FIS TEMEIDGRAY
N ALIHEILF BUUTNFREHEOA SWNDERA
, W A IBE L T S A TYATICINIVOP I
EEOT
KN
DUNT N U
SE.ETH F
CPAHE IDSHIVD HOHAEVE.ON T UT L
IT
ORDDS C A AON TLICAAM  IAS W TDD
TH T S LINSE IGO YLTOMI
ERG
IEISPRMREAT WS
ATPRANNMMCAOOSO S HEHOBOTHHA
'SH AELENLE
SHWE S TUST. O PL H
OW ARA.OTNT
WI DATROOUITSO TN C LN'E
ERSTVE RY  ASTHE INIWERETH HAMGT
REFOALSY YREHIRRUNNDRE AAD TSHMI
TAD OEAENEOM CT O CT DALOUPGRSI
RU TM WELD,,
ARHI
SOARETWA
EDAT A  IRAYNTTE H
SSISAVILHI
A R'R
MI LEX HORAVETU AUNWE WESS TLDN
HA OAYOMINERSIN WWA E
INFRO EM?RAN C>>ANUNIDO ILD OTOS
TEOD AVIN.EYCHEAE FFLNE